[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hi everyone welcome to the table
uh we are live here on sunday night
so glad that you are joining us
uh my name is karen miner and you are in
for such
a treat tonight i was just thinking gosh
if
if there's a service that really brings
together all of the elements of the
table
our values of being thoughtful inclusive
eclectic communal and authentic it's
this service
so you were in for a treat i'm not going
to delay any longer
we're going to get started but first
just welcome i hope you are in a comfy
spot where you can relax
soak it in feel connected
feel free to comment below so we can
welcome you personally
let us know where you're watching from
and also just a side note
brett our pastor will be back next week
um he has been off for the last couple
weeks which has really allowed us to
hear from some great members of our
community we had don jacobs
josh brock and then wait and see who we
have for you tonight
but really brett being out for
a portion of july taps into one of our
values that we have for rest and healthy
rest rhythms
it's not just brett taking a vacation
but it really is
uh tuning in to the fact that
he and the rest of us are all human we
all need rest we all need to
take a step back and refresh and
recharge and refuel
so that we don't burn out and so that's
what's been happening around here so
brett will be back next week and we're
really looking forward to that
um and why don't we go ahead and pray
and then
we'll jump into worship
god we center on you
we take this time to
circle around the table and remember
that you are at the center of it
you are the foundation of it and that
you call all of us to it each one of us
no one is left out
so god i pray that you would speak to
our hearts and our minds through this
service
through songs and words
and prayers god help us to
open our minds and our hearts to what
you have for us help us to
really really listen and
reflect and listen for ourselves
god for things that you might want to
make adjustments in us or help us to see
god so we give you this time
god i thank you for each person watching
i pray your blessings over each one of
them
and i just thank you for how you
orchestrate how you move
and how you're always with us in jesus
name
amen
hey you guys um so i'm so excited as you
can see
we have some friends with us tonight who
have not gotten to
be on our live stream yet since we you
know went into
hibernation for covid season um
but i'm really excited about having them
with us
this is gary pyland and his husband sean
and their friend eli
on the keys and uh gary is the music
minister
at um the united methodist church in
mesquite
and you have probably seen him and sean
around if you guys were with us when we
were meeting live
together in person way back when um
they join our table family regularly for
our sunday night services and we're so
glad to have them with us
and i'm really just so thankful you guys
for being a part of this service
it's just so meaningful to me to have
other voices um
that are a part of our community just
contributing to what we do here together
and um this is not a one-man show
by any means and we don't want it to be
that and
um just to have other voices joining us
it means the world so thank you guys
and we're excited they're gonna share a
couple songs with us and then
um we're gonna go into our message and
then we'll come back and i'll finish out
with a few songs at the end so
i'm gonna pass it off to you guys and
thanks again
thank you so much and we are blessed to
be part of this
worship service tonight with you we
enjoy um
going to worship when it was in person
and
and the messages that brett brings along
really
lifts us up and and feeds us in a way
that
it's been a while since it happened so
um we have a few songs
we know that um tonight's theme is about
transformation
and and how god's love and god's
movement and
power in our lives transforms us and so
we truly can have a graveyard experience
and turn it into a beautiful garden
with the love of god in us around us
[Music]
i search the world
but it couldn't fit me
man's empty praise and treasures that
fade
are never enough
then you came along
and put me back together
and every desire is now
[Music]
[Applause]
is
i'm not afraid
to show you my weakness
[Music]
[Applause]
is not a place
[Music]
[Applause]
is
nothing is better than
[Music]
you turned morning to dancing
you give beauty for ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who cares
[Applause]
[Music]
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one you care
you turn graves into gardens
you turn bones into
[Music]
[Applause]
you're the only one who cares
oh there's nothing
better than you there's nothing
[Music]
better
nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
armies you turn
season to highways you're the only one
who
cares you turn crazy
to gardens
[Music]
you're the only one who cares
so
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
and come to jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
now your burdens are lifted
and carried far away
the stain
so sing to jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
sing to jesus
[Applause]
sometimes we fall
so far
[Music]
sometimes the way is
then cry to jesus
pride of jesus
[Music]
fills the night
and when you can't contain your joy
inside
then dance for jesus
for jesus
dance for jesus
[Music]
and laugh on glory's sign
and fly to jesus
fight in jesus
[Music]
wow that was beautiful
thank you thank you thank you gary sean
and eli
that was a gift and um i'm just so
thankful
for you three um that was great
i almost forgot i had to talk after that
oh um but i i am
really really honored and excited
because i get to introduce our featured
speaker this week
um she is a good friend uh
she is incredible her name is
maggie tilford and um
you know maggie hi maggie hey
uh gosh where do i start i
it's it's very very hard to come up with
a very succinct
introduction um so i'm just gonna hit a
few
and the rest of you just know there's a
million other words
that and things that could be said about
maggie um she's incredible
she is one of the most thoughtful people
i've ever met
she tracks people very very specifically
um like you know that maggie knows you
she tracks you
she shows you love and care and honor in
very specific ways
that only can come from from being
someone
who just really really wants to know
your heart your soul what makes you tick
and it's something i
very very deeply appreciate about her
she's also very high capacity besides
prepping for the message this week she
has taught piano full-time she has
taught
is it preschool you do on wednesdays
with
a gaggle of little ones
and saving my day yes and
uh just done all the family stuff and i
mean just
very high capacity and still has time to
track our table community
pray for all of you um check in with
people
regularly like it just it blows my mind
um and also the last thing i'll say um
maggie is also deeply deeply committed
to
god and to walking the talk of the
gospel
and it's out of that depth of time she
spends in prayer
and studying the bible and serving
and loving out of that comes this
humility
and ability to really really
open minds and bridge people that are on
different sides of
of conversations issues
whatever and so i'm really really
looking forward to hearing the message
tonight and
i will just say buckle up you're in for
a ride
and without further ado this is maggie
thank you thank you thank you
um that means so much especially coming
from karen
um hello happy sunday everybody
welcome to the table um when we meet
live meet in person um
one of the most meaningful practices
that we have is to um
participate and communion together and
to share that
time and brett always leads us in an
invitation to the table that's a
old celtic invitation but one of the
lines in it
says this is the table
not of the church that uh
but of the lord and it is christ who
invites you
and i just want to start off by saying
how
very aware i am of that when i step
into spaces like this with you right now
um this is not my church
and this is not my table this
is the lord's and each one of us who
have been part of this service tonight
are responding to his invitation
and i hope that if you're here sharing
it with us you know that that means
you're included in that
and that you're welcome and wanted
and um i pray that that's made so real
to you
throughout this service um the last two
weeks we got to hear from different
speakers don jacobs and josh brock were
both
beautiful reminders of that to me i so
appreciated
the vulnerability and transparency that
they shared with
oh my gosh i i just um i just
loved it and i loved that as a community
um we got to hear their voices and their
perspectives and it just
it meant a lot um so i wanted to thank
them
for everything that they said and i'm
excited to follow after them
and um i actually kind of laughed
because as i was listening in last week
to what josh brock was sharing
he had like 45 disclaimers on his sermon
before he could speak
and one of them was that he was a bible
college dropout
and i just laughed because i thought oh
my gosh our table community gets two
weeks in a row
of backslidden bible college dropouts
because i myself
am also a bible college dropout and it
wasn't until last week when i was
listening to josh brock say that that i
realized
oh and we're both bible college dropouts
of the same bible college
and it might have even been the same
semester
that we dropped out or he might have
beat me by one semester
i didn't even know josh back then but um
it's just a
little unique commonality um in our
relationship that we share
so i don't know if that how that might
sit with any of you listening on tonight
um so wherever that lands us let it be
what it is
but i hope i hope you're up for this
journey together
um we as a community at the table have
been going through the book of luke
um this summer and tonight we're going
to be focusing
in on luke chapter 11
and um this is a passage where jesus
confronts the pharisees
and the religious leaders of his day
with six count them six different
rebukes which is weighty
and um actually in if you look in
scripture
they have a sub heading in my bible it's
called the
six woes and um
i i don't know how many of you might be
fans of the show
friends but um i am
i am a fan and um i feel certain
that if this passage was an episode on
the show friends the title of it would
actually be
the one where jesus ruins the dinner
party
because that is what we're about to see
um
jesus gets invited by a pharisee
to dinner and what you need to know is
that the pharisees
were his biggest critics the pharisees
were a group like a religious
sect of the jewish tradition and they
were
religious and legal experts in their day
and jesus comes to their house for a
dinner and gives them
a pretty scathing review like
it is awkward but here's what you need
to know
the pharisees prided themselves on
very strict observation of the legal and
religious codes and laws
of their day which is no small thing
because there were 613 of them in total
so their their pride and joy
was being able to follow every single
one to
perfection and that's what set them
apart from the other jews of their day
and so um as they invite jesus to their
house like the scene is set
up jesus comes in the house and
scripture tells us that he immediately
goes and reclines at the table
which the pharisee who invited him
looks over in complete shock and i'm
sure
offended because what it tells us in
scripture is
jesus did not wash before the meal
and if you know the pharisees and if
you've studied
anything about jewish law a great deal
of their law was based on cleanliness
purity all these rituals of food and
drink
and so this was a major statement
against
their religious system like it's one
thing in our day to not wash your hands
before a meal like even we do that but
this is
first century judaism where
the vast majority of people are dealing
in
agriculture and there's livestock
everywhere
and you know with the standards for
cleanliness were so different back then
so to not wash before the meal like as
michelle tanner would say like
how wood so i have her voice in my head
because my kids are
really into full house these days so
jesus is going to the house of the
strictest member of society and he
immediately sits down without washing
his hands
like that is awkward enough if only
it stopped there but here's the thing it
doesn't
actually i'm pretty sure that jesus did
this on purpose
because he uses this opportunity to go
in to a verbal public critique
of the pharisees and their hypocrisy
and inconsistencies within their
religious lifestyle
so um i i think that's like the
backdrop of the story and i think
probably it would be best if we just
read it together now that you can kind
of see the landscape of what's happening
here
but um let's go ahead i'm gonna read
from my bible and i think it's on the
screen as well but just
in case you're following along in your
bible this is luke 11
starting in verse 37.
when jesus had finished speaking a
pharisee invited him to eat with him
so he went in and reclined at the table
but the pharisee
noticing that jesus did not first wash
before the meal was surprised
and then the lord said to him now then
you pharisees clean the outside of the
cup and the dish
but inside you are full of greed and
wickedness
you foolish people did not the one who
made the outside make the inside also
but give what is inside the dish to the
poor and
everything will be clean for you woe to
you pharisees
because you give god a tenth of your
mint roo
and all other kinds of garden herbs but
you neglect justice
and the love of god you should have
practiced the latter
without leaving the former undone
woe to you pharisees because you love
the most important seats in the
synagogue
and the greetings in the marketplaces
woe to you pharisees because you are
like
unmarked graves which men walk over
without even knowing it
one of the experts of the law answered
him
teacher when you say these things
you are insulting us also and jesus
replied
and you experts in the law woe to you
because you load people down with
burdens they
can hardly carry and you yourselves will
not lift one
finger to help them woe to you because
you build tombs for the prophets
and it was your forefathers who killed
them so you testify
that you approve of what your
forefathers did they killed the prophets
and you build their tombs
because of this god in his wisdom said
i will send them prophets and apostles
some of whom they will kill
and others they will persecute therefore
this generation will be held responsible
for all the blood
of all the prophets that has been shed
since the beginning of the world
from the blood of abel to the blood of
zechariah
who was killed between altar and
sanctuary
yes i tell you this generation will be
held responsible for it all
woe to you experts in the law because
you have taken away
the key to knowledge you yourselves have
not entered
and you have hindered those who were
entering
when jesus left there the pharisees and
the teachers of the law
began to oppose him fiercely and to
besiege him with questions
waiting to catch him and something he
might
say so
as you can see was i right like super
awkward moment
jesus obviously knew how to ruin a
dinner party
and kill the mood super quickly there
was no like
testing of the waters or checking the
relational temperature in the room like
easing into it cushioning the blow no
jesus was a band-aid ripper and he just
went straight for that sucker and ripped
it right off
from the very get-go there was nothing
in him that wanted to like tiptoe around
pleasantries
and um yet it well
i'll say this if you know me you know
that that is not my style
i am all about the cushion
and the pleasantries and the tiptoeing
and the relational
mood in the room and i just want
everyone to be happy
that is my comfort zone so this kind of
a setting where jesus
is confronting people openly publicly
embarrassingly
not at all my cup of tea yet there's
something about it that for me is
extremely
comforting which i don't know if that
just makes me
like wise or crazy i'm not sure
but um i
i am drawn like attracted
to passages like this one where jesus is
confronting the religious leaders of his
day
years ago tony campolo and brian mclaren
actually wrote a book
and they titled it adventures in missing
the point
how the culture-controlled church
neutered the gospel
so these two men i actually have
really benefited from much of their
teaching over the years
and this book stood out to me most
though i have to say because of its
amazing title
which is where i totally stole the title
for tonight's
message that i'm doing um i titled it
adventures and missing the point
but the reason i did is because every
time i
read the interactions of jesus with the
pharisees or sadducees
or legal experts of his day i feel like
they could all be summed up in this one
sentence
you are missing the point
and here's the deal i said earlier like
the pharisees
were an ancient ancient group of
jewish um legal experts
and they laid the foundation of what is
now known as rabbitic judaism
and their name actually came from this
hebrew word
called parasa like pharisee parasa i
don't know
they're similar but um the word
the meaning of it was to be separated
or set apart like these were the people
who were like
we are going to be holy we are setting
ourselves apart for god
we are going to follow all the rules we
are going to do
all the things right so that we can be
connected to god
like they pursued purity with incredible
passion and they wanted nothing more
than to live
lives that pleased god they were super
hardcore about it and yet somehow in all
of that
jesus looked at their lives and said you
are missing it how can you be so
good at playing religion and so bad
at loving god how can you be so perfect
at following
every rule and yet destroy the very
foundation
and purpose for them in the first place
in essence he's saying
how can you be so good at performing
and so terrible at transforming
but here's where i would like to offer a
little word of insight
as an expert on the matter
um i happen to know a thing or two about
performing and i don't just mean that in
the external sense of being on a stage
or putting on a show
although i have had my fair share of
experience in those as well throughout
my life
but what i'm really referring to right
here is the
internal posture of performing
every personality profile and like
giftings
test or strength finders you know self
um you know um
survey that i've ever taken has ended up
labeling me and typing me with something
including the word
performer in it like that's always the
paraphrased version of whatever
personality type
i get so the struggle to perform
rather than transform is very real for
me
and that struggle doesn't just happen on
stages it happens
in my relationships it happens on social
media
it happens in my advocacy it happens in
spirituality it happens before god
and um in truth this is why
i am so attracted to passages like the
one we're talking tonight and others
like it
because i realize how desperately
i need it you see all too often
i fit the description of a pharisee
like them i am very good at following
all the rules
and from a very young age i learned
how to do it looking extremely
respectable in the process
i have always known how to like dot
all the eyes and cross all the t's and
to do it all in the name of god
and here's the struggle with performing
you can do all the right things and you
can get it
all right in the end and still end up
just as empty and broken as you started
so i have spent my adult life
learning that at the end of the day god
cares
very little for how i perform as a
christian
and very much for how i transform
as a person christianity
is worth nothing if not a transformation
of the heart
that overflows into a transformation of
our world
and i still remember the first time that
i heard
um a speaker he was a christian teacher
say
that jesus did not come to start a world
religion
and i was so shocked um partly because i
grew up in church and i was pretty sure
this guy was wrong
um but also because i was just offended
and i was thinking like if jesus did not
come
to start a world religion then what have
i spent my whole life getting
so good at but if you read the bible
over and over again we can see that
jesus does not talk about religion
instead what he talks about is setting
the world
right restoring our relationships and
our connection
to god and to each other the biblical
word for this
is reconciliation and we can see it
throughout scripture and especially in
the new testament
but i i don't want to spend over
you know i'm trying to be careful with
my time management but i did feel it was
really important
to just read a few of those passages
together to kind of give us the
foundation and the framework for what
i'm talking about
so i do want to start in ephesians 2
and um in ephesians 2
you'll see um if we start
i think in verse 15
um it says his purpose
was to create in himself one new man
out of the two thus making peace
and in this one body to reconcile
both of them to god through the cross by
which he put to death
their hostility he came and preached
peace to you who were far away and
peace to those who were near for through
him
we both have access to the father
by one spirit
also if you could also go to second
corinthians
um chapter 5 verse
17 is where we're gonna start
um and this is what it says
to find my place therefore if
anyone is in christ he is a new creation
the old has gone the new has come and
all of this
is from god who reconciled us to himself
through christ
and gave us the ministry of
reconciliation
that god was reconciling the world to
himself in christ
not counting men's sins against them
and he has committed to us the message
of reconciliation
we are therefore christ's ambassadors
as though god were making his appeal
through us
we implore you on christ's behalf
be reconciled to god
and the last one i want to read is
romans 5
8 through 11. let me go over to that
actually let's start in verse 10 it says
for if when we were god's enemies we
were reconciled to him
through the death of his son how much
more having been reconciled shall we be
saved through his life
not only is this so but we also rejoice
in god through our lord jesus christ
through him we have now received
reconciliation our english definition
for this world reconciliation means
to cause to coexist in harmony
or to make or to show to be compatible
jesus came to do two things to reconcile
us to god
and to reconcile us to our neighbor
which is why
if you were listening in last week when
josh was preaching out of luke 10
and one of the religious experts come to
jesus questioning him and saying
jesus what is the way to inherit life
how do we have eternal life and jesus
says
i don't know what does the law teach you
and
the pharisee says love the lord your god
with all your heart soul and strength
and love your neighbor as yourself all
of the laws that they followed were
summed up in these two things
that was the whole purpose of the gospel
to reconcile us to god
and to reconcile us to each other
the trouble is when people like me
get so caught up in preserving a system
and protecting our own standing within
that religious system
it's no longer for the sake of our
neighbor anymore
it somehow shifts to become all
about ourselves it's centered around us
and our own performance
sometimes even coming at the detriment
of our neighbors
which are the very people that it was
meant to reconcile us
to this is where
jesus steps in to my show and
into my performance and says maggie
i didn't want you to become a good
performer
i wanted you to become a transformer
you see it's not so much about being
right but about being
righted i want to just say that one more
time
it's not so much about being right
as it is being righted
and this particular warning is a spirit
uh or is a is one that i have heard from
god's spirit
many times i've become so accustomed to
it
because i am that natural born performer
and i slip into these patterns all the
time
most recently it has shown up in the
arena of social activism
i think like so many of us um
the increasing awareness of racial
injustice
and unrest has just weighed heavy on my
heart over the last year
i actually am helping to lead a teen
group on wednesday nights with maggie
porter right now and
um one of the boys in that group his
name is preston
shared a quote with me the other day he
said
racism is like an onion the more layers
that you peel back of it the more you
want to cry
and i could totally relate to that um
in my personal life i don't know what it
was
about this one particular event or why
this was the catalyst for me
but the day that i um
read about brianna taylor
being awoken in the middle of the night
and being shot eight times
um that was the layer of the onion
that just it
messed me up and um
a few days later i watched the video
of george floyd being slowly murdered in
the street
and i knew
that their lives demanded something of
me
not just as a white person but as a
christian
and someone who really believes that the
gospel but like the work of the gospel
is the work of reconciling the work of
the gospel
is the work of reconciliation so
um i just felt convicted
and like compelled to
well i didn't know i mean i would be
lying to you if i told you that i even
knew the first step
at what to do in becoming an ally on the
side of the oppressed in our country
this was a challenge that i was
absolutely aware
that i was unqualified for and um
i i had no ideas what eyes to diet
i did not know what t's to cross and the
performer in me
was scared to death to step onto that
platform
and get it wrong forever
exposing myself as someone who had
racist
ideas or racist attitudes working in my
own heart
and um then
it was in that place and that struggle
of just
lying awake at night wrestling with
these feelings
that the familiar voice and warning of
the spirit of god
um would come over me and say maggie
you're missing the point it's not about
getting it right
it's about being righted and
those were the words that i needed to
hear
because my desire to perform and to get
it right and to protect my own
reputation
or my own right standing all had to die
if i was going to enter into the work of
reconciliation
there are so many different examples in
my life that i could share with you
um where i've stood at this exact same
crossroads
facing the choice to perform
or to transform and um
this is not just true in conversations
about race it's true in our houses
with our children and our spouses it's
true in our workplaces this is true in
our friendships where we have to learn
to listen and understand the perspective
of someone else that has a different
experience than
us um this is true in our art if our art
is
ever going to mean anything we have to
let
go of that desire to perform and
look good on the outside it's true in
our activism
it's most certainly true in our churches
but if we want to be reconciled to god
and we want to be
reconciled to others we must learn the
art of transforming and
laying down our temptations to do so
lay down our temptations to perform
instead of transform so
um i was just thinking
to kind of bring all this home i wanted
to just make a little list together of
some tips that i feel
like we could draw from um jesus's
um set of woes for the pharisees
and i thought we could turn it into a
little survey
for ourselves to ex to better assess
our motives as we practice the work
of reconciliation in our own lives um
i was raised in small town lucas texas
and i heard jokes all the time that were
called redneck jokes and they always
started with the phrase
you know you're a redneck if blah blah
blah blah blah
so as i was writing this part of the
sermon out all i could
hear in my mind was you know you're
caught in performance
if so
jacob is helping me with slides tonight
thank you jacob
and um i just thought we would start
and go through some of these verses with
the pharisees and just talk about better
ways
to transform rather than perform number
one
you might be caught in performance if
you want
a checklist um i'm
taking this from verse 42 where jesus
tells the pharisees
woe to you because you give a tenth of
your mint and your roux
and all your spices and herbs but
you neglect justice and the love of god
and what he's talking about there is
like they're going through
and they're going through their
checklist of all the rules like okay
give a tint of your spice
give a tint of your roux give a tint of
your mint like all your every
garden herb and they're getting every
little thing on their checklist marks
marked off
except the larger picture of justice
and the larger picture of the love of
god in their world
and i feel that um
this is a temptation especially as a
white person i feel this because
checklists do a great job at protecting
me
um from looking bad in front of people i
like at the end of the day and you might
i mean like i said this could apply to
other things but
like in our jobs it's really nice to
have those checklists and feel like we
can hide behind them and be like
but i don't say this word and i've never
done this thing
and i always do this and i have these
friends
and you know whatever i mean for me like
you know in my
in my um attempt to do a better job at
becoming
racially aware and aware of my own
presence and how it affected people
i wanted a checklist so that like i just
wanted someone to tell me what to do
like
just tell me the right things to do so
that i am not at the end of the day
stuck in a category
of those bad racist people
the thing is that checklist does not do
anything on behalf of the oppressed it
actually
only benefits me and
i think we have to come back to the same
exact critique that jesus gave the
pharisees where he said
you should have practiced the latter
without neglecting the former for me
when i'm caught in these situations
where
you know i want to do everything right
it's not of course like i do
i still want to do everything right i
don't want to say the wrong things
but the bigger heartbeat behind it is
justice and love of god you have to
practice the latter
before you emphasize the former
so you might be caught in performance if
you want a checklist
um the second one is you might be caught
in a performance
if you look for an audience and
um i'm getting this from verse 43 where
he says woe to you pharisees
because you love the most important
seats in the synagogues
and the respectful greetings in the
marketplaces
i feel that this is especially true in
spiritual work and activism
and even in our relationships where it
can become very important to us that we
are
publicly viewed as the ones who are in
the right
um i feel like jesus is warning us
against this he was warning the
pharisees against
this and um for me
personally you know brett and i have had
a lot of discussions about this
and as we um you know were wanting to
step
further into this role of being allies
on the sides of
the people who are struggling in our
country the voices who have not been
heard and things like that
we had the opportunity to go to a couple
of protests
and or we took the opportunity and um
i feel like that was important for i
mean it was very important and
impactful for me um i feel like i needed
it more than anyone else you know
at the end of the day i think it served
to work on my own heart rather than you
know what it did publicly for anyone
else
but um stepping into those public
platforms there is a degree to where
that is
important as we enter into being
reconcilers
um there is a gr you know a degree to
where that is helpful
but one of the things that brett and i
have talked about and come back to
um in our conversations uh one night we
were laying in bed
and it was actually i went to my first
protest
and came home and you know spent the
whole rest of the day thinking about it
mulling on it chewing on you know what i
had seen what i experienced
and um at night time a lot of nights you
know
we both end up on each our each of our
separate side of the bed with our little
lamps turned on and you know reading
whatever book we're working through
i picked up this book that i was working
through on racial justice
and i looked over to brett and i just
said
um you know the
the protests is good work but it's what
happens the day after the protest that
actually matters
and um for me
i had to realize that this is about me
learning and becoming
a better person for the sake of the
better people around me
not just showing up with a banner and a
sign
and looking like i'm this great activist
um it's what happens the day after the
protest that really matters
um so number three
your public life looks different than
your private life you might be caught in
performance if
your public life looks different than
your private life and i think this is
what jesus was saying
in verse 44 when he tells the pharisees
you
are um you are like unmarked graves that
people walk over without even knowing it
if you um are a fan of the message
version which i'm a huge fan
um but if you ever read in that
translation
um eugene peterson
said it this way he said you're just
like unmarked graves
people walk over that nice grassy
surface
never suspecting the rot and corruption
that is six feet under
um that stings it stings
but i think it creates such a beautiful
picture of what jesus was trying to say
if what people see on the outside is not
a reflection of the work that's
happening
on the inside it's not worth anything
and actually oftentimes it's creating a
greater issue a bigger problem
so that internal work has to happen
and what is happening on the outside has
got to match up
um the last one i'm going to do number
four
you might be caught in performance if
your spirituality
separates you rather than sends
um verse 52 of this passage
is the one that breaks my heart more
than any of the rest of them
um i'm just gonna read it um one more
time
um but this is what it says
woe to you experts in the law
because you have taken away the key to
knowledge
you yourselves have not entered and you
have hindered those who were
entering and that
breaks my heart um
because the pharisees he's telling them
like
you have everything you need to do this
well
you you possess it all you have been
given the power
you have been put in the seats of
authority everyone's listening to you
you know the laws front words and
backwards you
know what this system is built on and
yet at the end of the day
you are not only failing to use them to
make yourselves better
but you're using them as
an obstacle to keep anyone else from
getting there either
and talk about an adventure and missing
the point
like we said earlier the pharisees
got their names from that word that
meant
set apart or separated and
here's the thing the work
of being separated or set apart for god
is the same work of being sent into the
world on behalf of others
um this dates all the way back
to the old testament at the first
covenant that god made with abraham
when he said i am blessing you to be a
blessing to the rest of the world
and if our spirituality at the end of
the day is only benefiting ourselves
we're broken we're a mess we have
entire we've gone on this grand
adventure to just miss the point
entirely
um we've missed the opportunity to
transform
and at the end of the day we've merely
performed and
i feel like jesus is trying to save us
from that um
we are being separated
so that we can be sent like we we are
being set
apart to be sent into the world not to
be separated from people
but to enter into
their struggle to stand in solidarity
with them that is the work of the gospel
that we are reconciling ourselves to god
and reconciling ourselves to our
neighbor
so if i was to boil down this whole
message
it would probably be from first john 3
where he teaches
us that the true love of god results in
the love of our neighbor
if we don't want to miss the point we've
got to
look out into the world around us look
into the eyes of our neighbor
and start being reconciled
i just want to pray to close us and
mindy is going to lead us in a couple of
worship songs
um
god i thank you
i thank you for your grace in this
journey
because everything that i've said here
tonight
has been a process
of walking in your grace your grace for
every misstep
that i have made
and for everywhere that i have been
ignorant or unaware
of the way that i am missing the point
myself
and i thank you for the way that you
keep calling us forward
drawing us into seeing those around
us
god i ask that you would make us a
people
who truly are reconciled with you
in such a way that we are compelled
and being sent out into the world
um to bring about further reconciliation
with our neighbors
i want that so badly god for myself and
and for this whole table community
um for the cities that we live in
for the people that we come into contact
with
so i thank you
for the work that you did
to draw us near
draw us near to yourself and i pray that
that is never in vain god
but um that is something that
begins in the personal and overflows
into the public sphere
it's in your name that we pray amen
thank you amen thanks max that was
so powerful um that was my second time
hearing it
and ah just so good
i just love your heart and your
vulnerability and
your um gift to
um craft something that's on your heart
in a way that the rest of us
can take it in and
i actually for those of you who have a
few more minutes to hang with us i
wanted us to
just spend some time um
in worship and music in a creative space
where we can open up our heart
and be in a posture of saying god what
is it in me
that needs to look different like where
is it for me that
transformation needs to take place or
maybe there are areas that you are
already
feeling the transformative work of god
in your life
and this is just a moment to soak in
that
and let him continue to do that work
in your heart none of us are too far
gone
and he is a god of redemption and
whatever it is that he
is placing his hand on in your life is
worth spending time
allowing him to continue his work
and i also have asked um jacob
to put up a link to a video that you
guys can check out later if you would
like
um it was it's like a music video of
sorts to a song
called my brother by the band the
brilliance
and it's a beautiful song super powerful
um and i think that the video that this
these people put to it is just a very
meaningful and powerful experience
in light of what maggie was talking
about where our transformation
should look like the work of god in our
world
it should change the way we view people
it should change the way we interact
it should change change the way um that
we
advocate for others um so anyways
jacob's gonna post that video i hope
some of you will take time to check it
out later and for those of you who want
to join us
for a few more minutes um for me
transformation sometimes looks like
taking time to just cry out and name
that i need
jesus i need him so badly
and that i know that i'm missing the
point you know
and giving him room to change my heart
so i just wanted to take some time to do
that together to cry out
and ask the only one who has been
capable of changing me
to do that work in me
my soul cries out
for you
[Music]
my bones cry out
these bones cry out
for you to live and move
cause only you
can raise the dead
[Music]
my soul cries out
for you
[Music]
jesus you're the one who
saves us constantly
creates us into
something new
[Music]
jesus surely you will
find us surely our messiah
we'll make all things new
will make all things new
jesus you're the one who
saves us constantly
creates us into
something new
jesus surely you will
find us surely our messiah
we'll make all things new
make me new god
make me new god change me from the
inside
change me from the inside make us
new make us anew
in my heart and my soul
i give you control
consume me from the inside out
lord let just disempores
become my embrace
to love you from the inside out
in my heart and my soul
i give you control
consume me from the end
side out lord
let justice and praise
become my embrace
to love you from the inside out
everlasting your life will shine
with all else fades
never ending your glory goes beyond
all fame and the cry of my heart
is to bring you price from the end
side our lord my soul he cries out
everlasting your life will shine with
all else faith never ending
your glory goes beyond
all fame and the cry of my heart
is to bring you praise from the
inside our lord my soul
it cries out from the inside our lord my
soul
it cries out to you
we cry out to you
we cry
change the skies
change the sky
you alone are my hearts
desire and i long
[Music]
you
jesus you're the one
who saves us constantly
creates us into
something new
[Music]
jesus surely
you will find us surely
our messiah we'll make all things
new will make all things
[Music]
new
thanks mindy thank you maggie for your
message
thanks to everyone who contributed to
the service tonight i want to
say a special shout out to jacob porter
who's been doing all of our behind the
scenes tech stuff making sure all of
these lime
live streams come together um so thank
you jacob for all of your hard work
and thank you for joining us tonight i
hope you
get the opportunity and take the
opportunity as this week goes on to
really
reflect on maggie's words and allow them
to
transform you and as you go
into your week i will leave you with
this benediction
you are a child of god this is true
on your best days it's true
on your worst days and it's true during
a pandemic
it's also true for those with whom you
vehemently disagree with
about everything from masks to politics
to schools opening back up
so as you go into the week ahead with
its yet unknown
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are and go filled with god's holy
spirit
and the desire to extend those same
gifts of grace and divine love
to everyone you come in contact with
especially
in online spaces be blessed and we hope
to see you back here
next week bye
you